[Rires]
s'il a été acquise oula oula
benjamin castaldi la source et gilles
verdez
et c'est très grave
benjamin castaldi portera un lourd
secret de famille depuis quelques jours
il est important aujourd'hui de révéler
en direct dans tpm place secret alors
cyril je vais vous laisser diriger
si benjamin ce serait très bien que
benjamin c'est énorme c'est un scoop
c'est en fait ce que vous êtes en train
de lire c'est très bien qu'ils le disent
oui sinon vous allez le dire oui je vais
le balancer voilà donc voila comme tu
veux benjamin d'accord vie va changer
je le sais est ce que tu es prêt à
l'annoncer
quoi vous allez enlever votre poitrine
ah oui c'est énorme c'est non ami oui
elle était vraiment désolé partout ouais
bah oui bah ça vous a déjà vu là il est
là il a une oreille
esprit ça concerne ma famille oui est-ce
que ça concerne mon grand fils oui je le
sais oui quoi coco crisp aux cobayes
vaisselle et depuis depuis un moment de
la salle a écopé vous et lui lui n'a
rien dit il est bien terrien en forêt
voilà quoi et c'est une bonne nouvelle
j'ai une bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle ouais c'est bath excuses battu
à minuit mathieu dénis à quoi tu m'avais
dit
mais chez les hommes félicitations à
baja nakatani et c'est pour ça qu'il a
pris un coup de vieux
je n'ai
ni castaldi
voilà c'est un beau surnom maintenant
papy casqués descend cette envie d'un
papy banshee bravo mon chéri ça va
arriver qu'on
ne connaît pas le sexe sans cornes c'est
fou by passera comme vous
personne
ne s'y attend pas que ça les robes
gagnent les chiens
merci oui ça a été très très lourd toit
de oui je suis très content je suis très
content pour toi benneteau susciterait
je repense aux trésoreries sont très
marion gravot c'est bon génial on
aimerait benjamin castaldi grand père si
on m'avait dit ça
bah bravo benja franchement qui ça va
pas on finit quand même un petit coup
sur la tête par exemple ce moment un
petit peu
un petit peu pénible quand même grâce à
lui je vois mon père a bien sûr
hydro-québec tarière camper un lagon
mais robert j'imaginais c'est fou ça
c'est fou quand il vous est le grand
père ivre alors il ya pas john gomery a
pas de fumée se dégage de son père mais
quand il écoute les grands pères et
grands-pères ça y est c'est fini c'est
fini enfin c'est sur nous non mais c'est
à dire que dans notre tête ça toujours
grand père hier samedi on l'a vu avec du
papy brossard
également cette fois ça y est on n'a
même plus besoin d'avoir isabelle st
louis sannié non mais ça y est la passe
et mme hassan yebda les balades en main
voilà bravo c'est bien
ça vous ça vous dégoûte un peu non tu
n'as pas du tout non non c'est génial je
suis très heureux pour vous mais c'est
vrai que voilà je sais que ça vous amis
quand même rêve voilà c'est normal non
ça m'a ému et voilà je serai comprends
bien vous donne les bons jeux comme
grand-père
lecture plus et votre fils va être
prêtes va avoir pratiquement le même âge
que le valais ainsi aussi ont leur est
bizarre mais je sais que c'est le fils
de castaldi m avec l âge maman fils à
ses membres est en fait longue parce que
s'arrête l'oncle 1 6 ess a raflé deux
essais de ses fils dont elles auront le
malheur qui vont se balader
six mois le fils de castanet 16 mois
mais recèlent moins d'enjeux les
biographes en effet six mois
mais voilà et donc lavallois bon c'est
vrai mais oui son oncle va avoir deux en
plus à tort d'avoir une vie de bâton de
chaise forcément bah oui tu en es là
maintenant mon choix si fabre à dire
vers quoi bâton de chaise ben parce que
je crois que le bâton culturelle
avec l as peut-être